les leaders politiques
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdo
politique votre rendez vous du dimanche
soir sur radio sensations en association
avec tv 78 épisodes 203 mon invité ce
soir et le maire ps d'orsay david ross
l'hebdo politique
david rose bonsoir bonsoir vous avez 51
ans et vous cumulez plusieurs casquettes
celle de chercheurs d'abord après des
études à la faculté de sciences d'orsay
vous obtenez un doctorat en physique
dans le domaine des lasers en 1998 vous
devenez ensuite enseignants chercheurs
dans cette même faculté vous démarrez
votre vie politique en étant membre du
conseil municipal puis maire adjoint de
la commune de bures-sur-yvette vous
devenez ensuite mr d'orsay en 2008
mandat pour lequel vous avez été réélu
en 2014 et en 2020 depuis 2015 vous êtes
le leader de l'opposition au conseil
départemental de l'essonne depuis 2016
vous êtes vice-président de la
communauté d'agglomération paris saclay
en 2018 enfin vous êtes devenu le
premier secrétaire fédéral du parti
socialiste en essonne et vous avez été
réélu en septembre à ce poste c'est
d'ailleurs une longue histoire entre
vous et qui vous lie avec le parti
socialiste vous êtes adhérent depuis
1987 vous aviez alors 17 ans qu'est ce
qui à cette époque vous avez donné envie
de vous engager en politique ah ça nous
replonge un petit peu en arrière c'est
en fait en 1986 j'étais lycéen au lycée
d'orsay et je me souviens il y avait des
petits mouvements estudiantins puisqu'il
y avait les lois devaquet qui était en
projet et il ya des jeunes qui étaient
venus de l'université pour essayer de
faire débrayer le lycée à l'époque le
proviseur avait pris le micro et il nous
avait interdit de le faire et moi je les
regardais avec un intérêt un peu
distancés et le fait que le proviseur et
dit je vous interdit de faire ça m'a
fait une sorte de déclic et voilà donc
je me suis retrouvé embarqué entre
guillemets dans cette période d'abord à
sos racisme en fait en 1986 et puis
ensuite en faisant mes études à
l'université avec l'unef id à l'époque
avait un lien très fort entre le parti
socialiste avec des grandes figures
comme julien dray par exemple sos
racisme et et l'unef id voilà donc j'ai
fait un peu comme obélix 1 j'ai mis le
doigt quand j'étais petit dedans et j'ai
tiff comme vous l'avez dit ensuite élu à
18 ans au conseil municipal de bures sur
yvette et depuis je suis élue sans
discontinuer depuis la situation du
parti a bien changé avec la crise du
parti socialiste en 2017 beaucoup ont
quitté le ps comme moi ce que vous avez
vécu cette période alors c'est dur c'est
quand on est des gens quitter un navire
la question c'est est-ce que je quitte
le navire ou est-ce que je reste fidèle
d'ailleurs on peut voir ça d'un point de
vue positif en dix ans le partizan a
essaimé
des personnes dans tous les partis parce
qu'on en retrouve à la france insoumise
bien sûr avec jean luc mélenchon qui
était du département de l'essonne on en
retrouve chez les verts on a en tout
chez les radicaux donc moi je suis resté
fidèle parce que j'estimais que c'était
pour l'instant l'outil qui était le plus
à même de faire la transformation au
quotidien c'est toujours ce qui m'a
motivé c'est d'être utile à ce que dans
ce que je fais depuis mes fonctions
d'élu mais aussi dans le cas de mon
métier dans la transmission du savoir et
pour moi il rester l'appareil qui était
le plus à même justement de permettre
cette transformation là selon vous
est-ce que c'est françois hollande qui a
terni l'image du ps françois hollande a
été au bout d'un cycle mais il a été
finalement le
la conséquence depuis on dirait je
dirais la fin du deuxième septennat de
françois mitterrand on n'a pas forcément
sus à la fois se rénover et prendre en
compte les enjeux de la société et donc
on avait un support important et ont
l'âme à mon avis mal utilisés au
quotidien et donc du coup voilà la
société a fait que c'est plus devenu la
première force de gauche même si elles
aspirent à le devenir à l'époque vous
étiez parmi le fronton parmi les
soutiens du président alors - comme j'ai
vous l'avez compris des journées bien
chargées moi j'étais surtout j'ai
mobilisé dans mes fonctions d'élu et
donc je comprenais ce que porter les
frondeurs mais j'estime qu'à des moments
où il faudra être en capacité de faire
entendre sa parole et puis une fois
qu'on a les mains dans le cambouis on a
les mains dans le cambouis donc c'était
je trouvais ça est assez particulier que
certains à la fois crache dans la soupe
comme on dit et en même temps les
responsabilités donc on peut s'opposer
en démocratie en général et dans un
parti c'est fait pour ça mais il faut
choisir un petit peu ces moments et
c'est vrai que ça a participé à la
cacophonie générale donc j'ai été
exigeant mais pas moteur dans la france
en 2018 lorsque vous avez été élu
premier secrétaire fédéral du parti
socialiste en essonne par les militants
essonniens vous aviez déclaré au
parisien je ne sais pas si le ps va
survivre aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
êtes rassurés oui parce que
effectivement j'avais jamais exercé de
responsabilité au sein du parti rpt je
veux vraiment je me focalisais sur les
fonctions d'élu et quand en deux minutes
18 je vois là je décide de mettre les
mains d'enfants oui c'est parce qu'il y
avait une vraie risque le parti
disparaissent et je voulais essayer
d'être modestement à mon niveau utile
pour essayé de réanimer les choses d'un
peu mobilisé les forces et on a réussi à
cela puisque je rappelle qu'on n'était
pas en capacité d'assurer des scores de
plus de 5% dans beaucoup d'élections on
a eu la séquence locales départementales
et municipales qui a conforté les
positions qui nous a permis aussi de
reconquérir des villes donc on n'est pas
aux gémonies qu'on n'est pas la première
force une fois encore centrales de toute
la gauche mais on est incontournable je
demande à vue des élections municipales
en 2020 les élections régionales
départementales en 2021 à l'échelon
local le ps on peut dire a bien résisté
en gardant les régions bretagne centre
val de loire bourgogne franche comté
occitanie et nouvelle aquitaine la
gauche a aussi remporté 26 départements
comment est ce qu'on explique cette
résistance au niveau local alors c'est
un bon exemple et moi j'ai plutôt envie
dire que cette résidence au niveau local
elle aurait dû être le socle quand on
parlait tout à l'heure de ce qui aurait
dû être pris en compte au niveau
national voilà le vrai reproche que je
faisais à l'époque du gouvernement des
gouvernements de françois hollande c'est
qu'il ne s'appuyait pas assez sur l'
expertise et sur l'expérimentation local
on avait des maires socialistes on avait
des conseils départementaux saucisses
des régions socialistes et on nous
expliquer ce qu'il fallait faire sur nos
territoires sans écouter ce que nous on
ressentait ou ce qu'on vivait et
finalement les maires et les élus de
terrain qui travaillent bien qu'ils
soient socialiste ou de la gauche
plurielle et ils sont réélus parce que
je sors ils font les choses sur le
terrain qui sont appréciés donc c'est ça
moi que je souhaite mettre en avant dans
mon engagement politique depuis 2018 un
homme incarne cette renaissance pour
faire renaître le parti socialiste qu'il
s'agit d'olivier fort kalou penser de
ces trois ans et demi en tant que
premier secrétaire fédéral du parti il a
été réélu récemment tout à fait alors il
a été un peu entre guillemets en
parallèle ce que j'ai fait c'est qu'il
n'était pas très connu quand il a pris
les rênes du parti personnes en
voulaient beaucoup pensé qu'il était là
pour fermer boutique il a eu à gérer le
déménagement de solférino des problèmes
aussi avec tous les permanences qu'il y
avait beaucoup de permanents il a fallu
faire des licenciements ce qui est pas
dans la nature de l'adn du parti
socialiste et donc il a dû gérer cette
situation de crise et refaire exister la
maison saucisson qu'il a été
légitimement réélu et voilà moi je salue
ce travail-là qui était important qui
est pas forcément très visible mais qui
était nécessaire dans ce jeudi les
militants ont désigné anne hidalgo la
maire de paris pour devenir la candidate
du parti aux élections aux
présidentielles de 2022 elle était
opposée à stéphane le foll le maire du
mans que pensez vous de ce choix alors
effectivement il a été élu quasiment à
80% je dirais pas que le vote était
connu d'avancé mais c'est vrai qu'il y
avait une telle médiatisation que lé
parti beaucoup plus tôt que stéphane le
foll tous les deux sont mères finalement
puisque maire du mans et maire de paris
donc ça 1,15 que je disais moi qui me
plaît c'est qu'un élu local et envies de
retrousser les manches pour appliquer sa
à l'échelon national
on avait besoin de quelqu'un qui porte
les couleurs parce qu'à un moment il y
avait aucun candidat donc elle s'est
déclarée on l'a vu à la sortie de l'été
stéphane le foll a voulu en fait en
étant candidat qui ait un vrai débat en
interne ce qu'on a pas eu le temps
d'avoir pour être honnête les délais
d'ici la présidentielle sont trop courts
pour qu'un vrai débat idéologique je
passe sur qui des vraies fractures
d'ailleurs idéologique entre 2 et donc à
une sorte de vote pas d'adoubement mais
qui était quasiment évidence à sa
personne c'était le meilleur timing
aujourd'hui cette semaine là pour
désigner le candidat du parti je sais
pas si c'est leur timing mais il y avait
urgence à faire quelque chose puisque
effectivement l'élection c'est au mois
d'avril là on commence à en parler un
petit peu il y aura ensuite les fêtes de
noël on sait que les français sont
légitimement concentrer sur l'aspect
plus familial et ensuite il faut que ça
reparte en janvier donc c'est important
de désigner un candidat ou une candidate
parce que maintenant il va falloir non
seulement avancé dans la campagne mais
aussi rencontrer les autres forces de
gauche les nombreuses polémiques dont
anne hidalgo fait l'objet à paris ne
peuvent-elles pas selon vous lui porter
préjudice
en tout cas les polémiques ça fait
parler donc ça permet de mettre des
choses sur sur la place publique sur le
débat après il ya toujours des choses
qui sont en positif d'autres négatives
mais ça c'est la chose politique
classique s'est passé pas un sujet nous
parlions tout à l'heure de l'ancrage
local du ps la maire de paris s'est
entouré d'élus locaux pour sa campagne
je pense au maire de roanne nicolas
mayer rossignol au maire de nancy
mathieu klein à la présidente de la
région occitanie carole delga ou encore
au maire de montpellier michaël
delafosse il y alla de potentiel
ministre vous pensez ils ont la stature
pour former un gouvernement pour la
france tout à fait ou vous même en
rajouter la maire de nantes qui est la
directrice de cabinet anne marlange
johanna rolland effectivement c'est des
gens qui ont une expérience alors plus
ou moins importante en fonction des uns
des autres et donc elle l'a souhaité et
c'est intéressant s'entoure
effectivement que je disais de gens qui
ont eu des exécutifs à gérer et qui
savent de quoi ils parlent moi qui sont
pas que des techniciens théorique de
partie entre guillemets et donc ça fait
une belle équipe pour faire campagne et
je souhaite qu'effectivement je leur
souhaite là une réussite totale et que
certaines deviennent ministres une des
premières propositions d'anne hidalgo a
été de double le salaire des enseignants
durant le prochain quinquennat
une mesure jugée démagogie qui réalise
par le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer r vous pensez vous
que c'est possible alors d'abord ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dans une
campagne présidentielle quand on a un
peu d'expérience le débat qui vient
souvent c'est la sécurité on le voit
encore le ton que prend ce démarrage de
cette campagne et puis l'emploi est en
fête rares sont ceux qui évoquent
l'action de l'éducation et donc en
amenant cette proposition a qu'une
proposition forte sur la table et qui
fait débat avec les réactions qu'on a vu
bon ça permet de faire le buzz
médiatique vous en tant que journaliste
vous savez ce que ça veut dire mais ça
permet aussi de replacer au centre du
débat la question de l'éducation et ce
qui est vrai toutes les études le monde
sait que les salaires des enseignants
francs sont inférieurs à ceux que l'on
voit en europe quand on voit par
ailleurs les missions des enseignants
est aujourd'hui rendu hommage à samuel
matt pâtit les conditions dans
lesquelles travaillent et là le respect
et la prise en compte de leur métier il
ya besoin d'une revalorisation
clairement du salaire des enseignants
alors après ce qu il faut aller du
simple au double c'est un affichage qui
est montré aussi comme une directive sur
un temps long je pense qu'il faut aussi
séparer les enseignants du primaire du
secondaire et du supérieur parce que moi
même étant du supérieur je demande pas
un doublement de dieu mon salaire donc
en fait il faut regarder aussi la
situation des uns des autres et qui est
en tout cas un effort transparente tout
soit mis sur la table et qu'on puisse
avoir ce débat là mais il me ça mérite
une revalorisation dans tous les cas
sont comme vous l'avez dit le moyen en
tout cas de mettre la question de
l'école comme un thème central sur la
campagne l'état devrait davantage
investir dans l'éducation selon le plf
2022 c'est déjà le ministère qui dispose
du plus gros budget avec 56,5 milliards
en 2022 est-ce qu'il faudra encore
augmenter le budget a pour moi c'est
crucial et quand je dis l'éducation on
pense bien sûr à nos enfants mais moi je
pense même à la question de l'éducation
tout au long de la vie on va avoir des
métiers qui vont changer et donc il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de permettre à
des gens d'avoir des der qualification
professionnelle de les accompagner on se
retrouve avec des drames humains de
personnes qui à 50 55 ans se retrouve au
chômage qui ont travaillé toute leur vie
dans une direction qui ont vraiment
participer à l'économie à l'industrie
française et qui se retrouve mis sur le
chemin la route et ça c'est pas
acceptable donc il faut imaginer que
tous les établissements que ce soit
collège lycée ils peuvent être ouverts à
d'autres horaires avec d'autres
fonctions et moi je moi je plaiderai à
mon niveau en tout cas pour qui ce
brassage est donc vraiment l'éducation
soit au coeur au coeur de la société
puisque nous parlons de l'école je me
dois de vous faire réagir sur les
hommages qui ont eu lieu ce vendredi
dans les établissements scolaires un an
après la mort de samuel patxi professeur
d'histoire-géographie à conflans sainte
honorine vous avez j'imagine été très
touché en tant qu'enseignant par ce
drame oui parce qu'il y avait l'air
imprévisible quand on voit le côté
horrible à la fois du drame et puis la
manière dont ça s'est déroulé c'est
quelque chose qui est effectivement
inacceptable quand on a la fibre de
vouloir transmettre un savoir de vouloir
aussi susciter le débat donc c'est vrai
pour les enseignants comme les
journalistes et donc c'est à chaque fois
des crimes qu'il faut combattre par
rapport au drame humain de la personne
concernée mais par rapport à ce que ça
représente dans notre société et dans
notre république et je dois avouer que
en venant à votre émission j'écoutais la
radio il y avait donc des témoignages ce
qui s'est passé cette semaine sur les
témoignages et c'était très intéressant
d'entendre des jeunes et je trouvais que
c'était bien de la part des journalistes
de mettre ça en avant des jeunes entre
guillemets des banlieues qui ont un
certain accent et qu'on pourrait qu'on
avait il ya un an plus tôt montré comme
étant des gens qui trouvaient que
finalement ils avaient entre guillemets
bien cherché j'ai trouvé qu'un an après
les positions sont beaucoup plus
muri et ça fait chaud au coeur vraiment
de voir qu'à une réaction de jeunes 12
13 14 ans qui qui s'associe à ça et qui
le critiquent fortement autre sujet sur
lequel anne hidalgo et investissent élus
de la voiture le prix du gasoil est à
son plus haut niveau historique
la candidate a donc suggéré de baisser
temporairement la tva sur le carburant
pour soulager le pouvoir d'achat des
français certains vont dire que ce n'est
pas une mesure écologique vous qu'est ce
que vous en pensez alors qu'anne hidalgo
quand elle interdit la voiture sur les
berges on dit qu'elle est trop écologie
quand elle fait cette proposition on dit
qu'elle n'est pas assez évidemment
l'automobile ça fait partie du coeur et
du quotidien de la vie des français ce
qu'elle a voulu signifier moi je la
rejoins là dessus c'est que qu'on ait
une politique écologique une politique
de transition c'est essentiel c'est
vital pour notre société mais on peut
pas à chaque fois qu'il ya des mesures
les faire porter uniquement sur le
portefeuille des français et donc il
faut que des compensations ça veut dire
que dans un premier temps soyez des
moyens de transport alternatifs qui sont
déjà opérationnels soit en tout cas dans
la période de transition il faut qu'un
effort pour que ceux qui ont besoin de
leur voiture pour se déplacer ne soient
pas pénalisés sur leur pouvoir d'achat
et ne fasse pas ça au détriment par
exemple de leur éducation de la culture
ou de la santé donc c'est pour ça que
c'est un tout un équilibre à avoir et
c'est dans sa proposition c'est pas un
engouement pour le tout voiture ce qu'on
peut pas l'accuser au moins de vouloir
favoriser le déplacement de
l'utilisation la voiture à paris
toujours concernant la voiture anne
hidalgo s'est prononcé pour un
abaissement de la vitesse maximum sur
autoroute on ne pourrait alors rouler
qu'à 110 km heure au maximum quand on a
vu les réactions qui avait entraîné la
règle des 80 km heure vous n'avez pas
peur que cette mesure passe un peu ne
passe pas justement auprès des français
alors c'est un vrai sujet je dirais que
ça dépend un peu des moments moi je
trouve que les réformes pour l'autoroute
j'ai rarement l'occasion d'être au
dessus de 110 m haies sera là parce que
je suis souvent suite au / / / des
heures de pointe mais c'est vrai que il
faut qu'un vrai bilan sûr il ya la
question de sécurité la question de la
pollution les voitures ont beaucoup
évolué et je dirais presque c'est terry
mais qu'il faudrait différencier la
vitesse de la voiture en fonction de la
voiture sert si vous avez une voiture
hybride ou une voiture totalement
électrique c'est pas le même bilan de
consommation en termes de en termes de
co2 si vous êtes sur du pur diesel ou un
moteur à essence classique donc là
encore c'est pour lancer le débat sur la
circulation je pense pas franchement tu
l'as la campagne puisse porter
présentiel sur ce type de type de
mesures - tant que maire je suis
beaucoup plus porté sur une limitation à
30 km à l'heure dans toutes les villes
parce qu on a des comportements on voit
des habitants et même des fois des
parents une fois qu'ils ont déposé
l'enfant repartir à des vitesses folles
en mieux en milieu urbain j'ai vu une
dérive depuis plusieurs années on
partage avec de nombreux maires et en
plus c'est un lie un impact de pollution
très très fort de musan sonore donc moi
je suis plus attaché sur les réflexions
et des débats sur la vitesse en milieu
urbain et périurbain que sur les grands
axes ou alors on a dix autos autres en
europe ou même la vitesse et non
limitées en allemagne notre en allemagne
par exemple donc je pense que le pour
moi le vrai sujet il est plutôt dans un
milieu urbain un débat majeur de la
campagne présidentielle sera là très
brûlante réforme des retraites plusieurs
fois repoussée elle devrait selon le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
être mise en oeuvre dès le début du
prochain quinquennat quel est votre avis
sur le sujet abbas est clair que si on
veut garder cette cette retraite par
répartition et papa rentrée sur par
capitalisation il faut la sauver donc là
encore il faut tout remettre sur la
table avec des vrais chiffres
et pâques parce que souvent la réforme
des retraites elle a un peu saucissonné
on vous parle et les avantages de
certains des avantages de d'autres mais
on met jamais tout sur la table et il
faut qu'il faut qu'il y ait un équilibre
et la question de la pénibilité du
travail qui souvent à la laque centre à
des réformes doit réellement réellement
être mis sur la table oui moi je suis
enseignant chercheur donc ça s'applique
déjà on doit on doit travailler jusqu'à
67 ans la question c'est patent l'âge
limite de retraite j'ai eu cette semaine
des cours à donner est toujours plaisir
de rencontrer des étudiants
je vais pas faire des paris sur la
commune mais je suis pas sûr qu'à 66 ou
67 ans si je dois être devant trente
étudiants en classe je pourrais le faire
mais est ce que je serai utile pour eux
parce que c'est la meilleure place que
je devrais avoir ce qu'il faudrait pas
qu'ils aient à ce moment là des
fonctions pour un mot métiers qui
permettent de travailler et de
transmettre cette expérience savoir mais
pas de la même façon donc l'enjeu il est
là il est l'âge et il est les conditions
avec lesquelles on va exercer son métier
vous même peut-être à 67 ans vous serez
ravis de pouvoir former des jeunes
journalistes en leur racontant vos
histoires ce que vous avez vécu mais je
suis passé au vous aurez forcément envie
d'être en direct à la tous les jours à 5
heures du matin ou à 23 heures le soir
où on verra dans quelques années autre
sujet chaud le nucléaire emmanuel macron
a lancé cette semaine le plan france
2030 un plan massif d'investissement de
30 milliards d'euros dans lequel il
décide de réinvestir dans des petits
réacteurs nucléaires notamment c'est une
bonne décision selon vous oui alors
c'est étonnant qu'elle soit prix de là
encore à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle ce qu'il est comme
président de la république sortant et la
question du nucléaire alors ça c'est le
côté un peu français un peu extrêmes le
nucléaires étaient boudés pendant depuis
un grand nombre d'années décrié par
certains en disant tous il faut sortir
du nucléaire et on avait comme un
m'oublier que c'est ce qu'a fait
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
voulue par le général de gaulle alors
bien sûr il ya des centrales
vieillissantes donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut regarder l'état des centrales
regardez le coût des investissements
pour les rendre opérationnelles en toute
sécurité et là il ya une vraie culture
est un vrai savoir-faire en france c'est
un coup mais c'est notre histoire notre
histoire depuis 50 ans et puis
effectivement il ya des nouvelles
générations qui permettent de faire des
réacteurs plus petit et ça reste ça
reste alors c'est devenu maintenant
quasiment à l'abandon il faut faire que
du nucléaire alors là moi je dirais pas
jusqu'à ce travers la même si en tant
que scientifique moi j'étais plutôt un
supporter de cette filière là il faut
trouver une solution mixte où il ya à la
fois des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire
mais le vrai débat qui n'est pas posée
c'est pas tant la sécurité de l'énergie
nucléaire c'est les déchets il reste une
réalité et pour l'instant on n'a pas la
solution scientifique pour non pas votre
génération ou vos enfants mais celle
d'après d'après d'après et là ça peut
devenir un vrai problème dans 500 ou 600
ans et on doit aussi anticiper ça donc
il faut à la fois travailler sur la
sécurité sur la question des déchets et
mais pour reprendre une formule célèbre
en même temps il faut qu'ils aient ce
mix entre les énergies renouvelables et
le nucléaire alors justement dans quel
autre énergie renouvelable
la plus prometteuse ça reste l'hydrogène
elle est très compliqué il ya déjà des
sauts technologiques à avoir et puis il
ya les fameux débats sur l'éolien et le
domaine liés à l'eau on a comme un
littoral extrêmement conséquent et donc
on sait qu'on va avoir des effets
climatologiques assez important mais qui
peuvent aussi générer de l'énergie donc
là encore il faut trouver la bonne
solution mais plutôt que d'imposer moi
je serais pour qu'un vrai débat avec une
fois encore la celle l'enseignant qui
parle les chiffres sur la table pour
savoir de quoi on parle explique aux
gens parce qu'à un moment quand il ya
des décisions démocratiques qui
s'imposent elles peuvent être
douloureuses mais il faut qu'ils
comprennent que on n'a pas le choix et
que en tout cas le pétrole on est on
arrive on le dit depuis - depuis que je
suis tout petit mais là on le voit avec
le prix d'ailleurs la pompe le pétrole
vie quand même ces dernières années et
donc il faut qu'on ait conscience que
cette
toute cette économique est basé sur le
carbone elle risque de s'effondrer du
jour au lendemain et donc on a cette
responsabilité en tant que politique et
scientifique d'ailleurs d'anticiper et
de porter le débat et de prendre des
décisions l'écologie c'est l'une des
priorités des français mais vous n'êtes
pas les seuls à gauche à vous
revendiquez écologistes la france
insoumise et europe ecologie les verts
concurrence aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste seriez-vous à titre personnel
favorable à une grande alliance de la
gauche pour les présidentielles ah bah
je suis tout à fait favorable mais elle
est surtout indispensable
d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai mené pour
essayer de faire basculer le département
descendons n'a pas réussi mais on avait
fait naturellement l'essonne avec un axe
où on retrouvait toutes les composantes
de la gauche sans aucune volonté
hégémonique du parti socialiste parce
que quand on voit les miettes mans
actuellement il ya je les dis a pu
vraiment un parti en tout cas gauche qui
est dominateur et il faut qu'on ait un
programme commun qui soit applicable
avec toutes les composantes et qu'on
décline à l'échelon local et est bien
sûr l échelon national les sondages
placent aujourd'hui anne hidalgo entre 5
et 6% des intentions de vote à peu près
autant que le score de benoît hamon en
2010 est ce que cela vous inquiète pour
le moment ouais alors oui et non sire
que benoît hamon a finit effectivement
un score très bas qui est le score pour
l'instant annoncé anne hidalgo mais sauf
qu'il avait démarré très haut quand il
était sorti de la primaire je crois
qu'il était donné à 13 ou 14% donc c'est
ce qu'a très bien dit d'ailleurs olivier
faure
cette semaine la question c'est la
dynamique d'une campagne donc on a
maintenant une candidate on a un
programme il ya un réseau de militants
donc elle va rentrer en campagne il y
aura des rencontres avec yannick jadot
plus naturellement que par exemple avec
jean luc mélenchon puisqu'on sait qu'il
souhaite candidats on a d'autres
candidats intéressants arnaud montebourg
qui qui parle de ce qu'il a été au parti
socialiste et il porte aussi des
thématiques intéressantes et donc cg
personnes vont faire campagne on est au
mois d'octobre et je pense qu'il y aura
certainement un point qui sera fait au
mois de décembre mais j'imagine pas la
fin que tout soit candidat parce que là
c'est la défaite assurée assuré pour la
gauche façon maintenant un sujet plus
local pour terminer cette émission la
semaine dernière les marges des terres
ont vu plusieurs centaines de militants
dénoncent et l'artificialisation des
sols en ile-de-france dans la ligne de
mire des manifestants
le projet de la n 18 du grand paris
express le projet de métro qui reliera
le plateau de saclay à versailles dans
les yvelines le député de votre
circonscription cédric villani s'est
déclaré contre ce projet en tant que
maire d'orsay c'est un dossier que vous
connaissez bien on imagine quelle est
votre position sur ce projet alors je
parlerai prononcé revealing mais je
crois que sa position est un petit peu
plus subtil que ça c'est qu'il est pour
l'arrêt du projet après saclay circling
18 partira de la gare de massy ont la
partie ouest voilà pour la partie ouest
donc moi ce qui était important et en
tant que maire danse et bien évidemment
c'est qu'on est un transport en commun
structuré très vite qu'ils puissent
justement relier massy au plateau de
saclay et qui surtout participe au
désengorgement routier qu'on observe
tous les matins et qui va s'amplifier
avec l'arrivée des organismes qui ont
été prévus par l'état donc il était pour
moi impossible qu'ils aient pas un
transport en commun les services de
l'état parce que ce qu'en gestion nous
ont proposés on a même imposé un métro
qui s'appelle la ligne 18 avec les
arguments qu'ils donnent donc peut-être
qu'avec notre solution mais maintenant
qu'elle est lancée il faut qu'elles
aboutissent voilà moi ce que je souhaite
pas c'est qu'on dise on arrête la ligne
18 qui rien à la place or on sait quand
on a un peu d'expérience qui est lancé
les appels d'offres ont été lancés le
tunnelier présent cette ligne 18 elle
est partie et
mon avis il faut qu'elle soit fait le
plus rapidement possible sinon on aura
une thrombose sclérose qui sera présente
sur notre opération d'intérêt national
et ça ira à l'encontre du développement
de l'université et de cette opération de
kloster scientifiques et les
manifestants qui défendent les terres de
saclay alors les manifestants ils ont
ils ont raison dans la mesure où ils
portent leur
leurs projets de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des terres je
rappelle quelques sur le yen ya eu un
équilibre a été trouvé il ya deux mille
trois cents hectares de terres agricoles
qui sont sanctuarisés et on regarde ça
il ya 300 hectares de terres qui ont été
vouées au développement de ce cluster
économique sur lequel vient la ligne 18
leur combat que je que je peux rejoindre
et dire on est contre ça bon ça c'est
leur position extrême mais leur combat
que je peux rejoindre c'est dire
attention il faut pas que cette ligne 18
viennent ensuite consommer les fameuses
terres qui sont préservés et donc là
dessus moi je serai totalement d'accord
et en soutien avec eux pour dire que en
tout cas nous le projet tel qu'il est
prévu il doit développer mais pas au
delà merci beaucoup d'avoir à vous
d'avoir été avec nous et d'être venu
dans l'hebdo politique je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire ps d'orsay nous on se
retrouve dimanche prochain à 19h mon
invité sera alors philippe jura vers
conseiller régional de la france
insoumise très bonne soirée à tous
l'hebdo politique
[Musique]